whatever the last several weeks been
like with you hearing the response from
fans as they watched the show you've
gotten some love and certainly some some
criticism as well yeah yeah I've got a I
soak still getting the hate you know I
think that's always gonna be a component
because anytime you and I knew much I
knew getting into this what I was
getting myself into so that was to be
expected but I'm also getting a ton of
love my basic mantra it's always been
look you have to be able to laugh at
yourself that's so important you have to
be able to love yourself and laugh at
yourself to be happy and that's why it
doesn't bother me and I tell these
haters they come at me but leave your
neighbor alone it'll leave it leave
other people own I can take it because I
put myself out there you have been
getting some other 90-day fiance
franchise people have even been coming
at you and saying you know that you're
you're not as loved did you think you
are I mean is this affecting you
emotionally at all or are you that used
to the bullying and you just put up that
wall and you're okay not at all and a
lot of my it's like a lot of my my
comments are humor you know I tell
people I'm kind of a really big deal
because well I think I am and I've been
saying that for the last you know you
know 20 years my fans love me and I love
them and and it's just like I will I do
these live streams whenever I can I'm so
busy but I'll oh yeah somebody will call
in and they want to be a guest and I'll
be in their living room and they
literally lose their Cheerios it is like
and for me I'm like they're like one
girls like I'm gonna cry you know I
can't breathe I'm like okay breathe and
don't cry it's just it's just big Edie
you know no you know relax so it's I'm
having a lot of fun I'm getting a lot
more love at this point than I am the
hate so that certainly helps yeah I'm
Mikey Michael
I'm her King she's my queen you say oh
my god I just want to look at you
well speaking of love the last time I
saw you in our studio you were you know
raving about you and Rose Marie's love
and now fans are wondering where things
are at between you two what can you tell
me about the status of your relationship
now I can just say that I'm happy that's
all I can tell you I'm very very happy
okay well I love hearing that what about
these rumors people were saying that
Rose Marie is engaged to a woman now you
know half the stuff I read online I do
not have to stuff more like 90% of the
stuff that I be online it's not true
it's it's people grabbing information
they're grabbing bits of bits of
information you know kind of like and
they're just creating you know fake news
it's they don't know what's going on I
know what's going on in my heart so is
Rose Marie engaged to a woman right now
I have no idea I haven't even seen the
article IVD how do you have no idea yeah
I mean I mean I heard people will talk
about it but Ivan I didn't I'm not I'm
not I mean I haven't seen well you have
to know she's engaged to a woman or not
right I can't answer that answer that
you know that um so are you to
quarantine
together I cannot answer that what do
you have to say to people who have
continued to have commentary about the
age gap between you two um well like I
said before when I when I first met Rose
I I said hey look I'm old enough to be
your father I'm you know I'm 54 years
old and well she's now 24 so anyways um
but I still it hasn't changed our
feelings haven't changed age is not an
issue for us that's all I can say what
drove you to feel those feelings for her
then admiration and the fact that I
really didn't think I had a chance
because she was in the Philippines and I
was in San Diego and there's like even
though we were it was all like giddy
giddy lovey lovey at first in my mind
I'm like okay this is just entertainment
it's not gonna turn into anything but it
and and that was and that so at first it
was the same thing for me because of our
huge you know geographical you know
difference like we were in two separate
countries so that was safe for me like I
knew it wasn't gonna work out but then
slowly but surely I started to have
feelings for her we would talk every
morning we would talk two or three times
a day and at night she was the first
person I talked to when I woke up and
the last person I've talked to you
before I went to bed it well what is it
about when you say admiration do you
mean you were drawn to how much she
admired you yeah they just did she
wanted to talk to me like she wanted to
UM see me every day she wanted to get to
know me I was certainly admiring her as
well it wasn't okay it's a 50/50 thing
it's yeah wasn't and it was I mean I
even felt like those feelings in awhile
and I was with my ex you know that's you
know she thought I was a hero I was
going to design school and you know that
and I was a professional and that sort
of admiration a lot of people talking
about your throwback photos that have
gone viral a sexy big Edie were you
surprised by that what is up with that
oh my god I was dating my ex-wife I
think it was 1988 this is the
honest-to-god truth
um I joined a gym a really nice gym in
San Diego although I didn't work out for
the first two months I have to admit
that I joined I didn't work out for two
months and then COBIT hit so but I'm
telling you once this quarantine is over
I'm gonna get you know get being
inspired to get back to the that they're
calling me and used to be a model I'm
like well thank you very much you know
and then one of my waiters pictures are
like wait when I waited see it was like
you look like Patrick a young Patrick
Swayze and whatever so yeah so and and I
was you know i'm i fluctuate through my
life like I'm fit you know one year and
that I'm not the next but you know I
don't think I have a choice I'm thinking
I'm gonna have to because a lot of
people are saying Edie you know they're
saying two things I mean like Edie you
really need to you know lose weight and
please cut your hair those are my two
and they say it in a nice way too well
most of it you're gonna get back to that
model
you know it man I'm inspired so are you
gonna start doing some at home workouts
everybody's doing it in a quarantine you
know what I'm not inspired yet to do
that and I'm walking a lot with Teddy
but um I am down like seven pounds but I
have a long way to go I just can't give
up my molbeck I know I'm with you you
gotta have the wine do you have a
weight-loss goal I want to drop 35
pounds my goal would be dropped 35
pounds by August 29th my goal will be
the drop 35 pounds and so you are you
know a lot of people as you said I've
been talking about different scenes the
leg shaving seemed um don't be mad at me
but um last night when I noticed that
your legs were kind of like mine they
were airy so I'll make you do it if you
shave your legs I'll shave my beard tell
me what was going through your mind that
okay so first of all I live in San Diego
you live in Los Angeles the women here
as well as men they laser their their
legs I mean so it was it was an
environment that I'm familiar with and
when I started to give Rose her leg
massage I I just it just was it's
through me it threw me a little bit and
I didn't mean to react the way I did but
I was just like oh my god so the next
morning you know I said hey you know I
will you know um I offered to shave her
legs and she said no and you know I you
know I was and then she said if you
shave you I'll shave my legs if I can if
I can shave your beard you know or if
you shave your beard so we both ended up
shaving ourselves and and it worked out
but yeah I got a lot of a lot of heat
for that so there's a test that you can
take yeah that's me no yeah it's a it's
a test for
for I know if you understand it's STD
which is I think it's a blood test and
they just test to see if you have like
sexually transmitted disease so that so
I was asking if you're willing to take
that test I will never ask you a and
another question about your past it was
a pointless the STD test request was
much talked about Oh most certainly
okay so hindsight's 2020 and I had a
awesome conversation with Tiffany about
two weeks ago and she's great at giving
me feedback as you know and she's like
that if you because the first thing I
did when I got back from the Philippines
as I went and got an STD tests and I'm
clean but my daughter's like you would
have got the test and then asked
rosemarie hey look I still have
questions about your past you know I
took a test will you that was the right
thing to do obviously I didn't do that
so so great advice from my daughter and
but I you know and you saw what happened
you know it almost you know it was no
must cost me our relationship that was
insane we want to face me being in that
trust me I've been offended I don't mean
to offend you
so I'm not comfortable well you've had
you've had kind of wild requests but
you've also made uh made big sacrifices
I mean you you bathed with her dad
essentially not essentially I did oh my
god oh my god and got it
God is with a gaawd I'm kidding so yeah
well well you saw that well the night
scene before was so that so the dad had
left and then he came back we all had
dinner and he left and then all of a
sudden he's back I'm like what in the
heck are you doing here
and then he's like oh I'm gonna I'm
gonna sleep between you two because I
don't trust you
so I wake up and I'm just I'm already
miserable and then I'm like let's go
take out I need to I need to go take a
bath
so I didn't even know where the bath was
I had no idea I never asked and then
sure enough we're walking by her dad's
room and it's like hey I want to I want
to I want to beige with you I'm like
okay so we walked another 6 feet over
this 50 gallon drum of water and hence
you know the bath scene with her dad I'm
dropping the soap it's surreal again
Rose is sitting there they're hosing me
up and though it is freaking freezing
the water was actually really really
cold so I was really really cold and
then I looked down and I saw what I
didn't even know what it was it it what
it was at first but because it was
almost doing like this it looked like
from like the Mutant Ninja Turtles that
little that little country guy it was
actually a rat and then I asked Rosa go
oh my god I scared the crap out of me I
jumped into the room and I'm like what
is that and I was at a mouse or a rat
she goes she's like I think so so she
didn't even know what it was so and I I
mean God forbid I probably slept with
that thing the night before what would
you say now about your suspicions that
Rose was just in this for money do you
still feel that way um we're still
exploiting that like it is at this point
we're still and I still have to answer
question at this point I still have
suspicions at this point in the show you
mean yeah yeah okay um and what about
your daughter has she at this point
accepted and I'm talking about in your
real life as are you guys back on track
you said you've talked to her and got
her but you know thoughts on the show
and that so
what what is you and your daughter's
relationship now when I got back we went
out to our favorite restaurant and I
mean it's we were both crying I mean
we're both in tears and I learned not
only was I not listening to because my
daughter was when I first told her I'm
doing this she's like and her and her
mom were like super fans of the show I'd
never seen the show before yeah that
they knew what was what was coming and
so they were a hundred percent against
him so my daughter just kept texting me
and we're I really screwed up as I
wasn't listening to her basically I was
able to explain to her or and apologize
that because she was more hurt because I
wasn't listening to her and then and
then she was going through a lot of
stuff in her life that I didn't realize
she was she was she lives in Vegas and
with her her mom and her and her stepdad
and they were yeah they were they were
dealing with you know financial stuff
and and and you know she was freaked out
about that and then her dad wants to
marry at 23 so I can't imagine you know
what she might have been going through
so it was a wonderful tearful and we're
actually in a better place than we were
before like even before this because now
we can now where the very honest with it
with each other which is even better so
we're in a great place
well is Rose still in your life I can
just tell you I'm very happy and I got a
bigger house you're in it I had to get a
bigger I had to my mom's moving in so
well maybe you had to get a bigger house
to move some other people into we'll
have to see you have to wait you have to
worry it's gonna be awesome
[Music]